- [Judith] My name's Judith Resnick.
I'm the Arthur Liman Professor
of Law at Yale Law School.
We, the Liman Center,
along with Dwayne Betts,
the Liman Center being Jennifer Taylor,
shout out here who's here.
There's a report about us
and if anybody wants to know
more than I wish we could,
we had to tell you about
solitary confinement.
There's a report called
"Time in Cell" just out
about more than 50,000 people
in solitary confinement
in the United States.
So we, Freedom Reads, Peter, Diane,
Whitney Humanities plus plus,
are all very glad that you're all here.
I was actually, at the
law school right now
there's another conference
called Access and Accountability
run by what is called the Mafia,
the Media Freedom of Information Clinic.
And I wish that all 60 of those people
could be also sitting here.
And I did pitch "please
think about and talk about
and write about, and thank
goodness you do some,
the state of incarceration."
I'm gonna start by introducing
some of the themes of the
panel and our discussion
with a little bit of pictorial and text
while also, and then thereafter,
each of our panelists is going to speak
in the order in which
they're seated, actually.
Elizabeth Hinton, and I'm not gonna,
I think everybody's bios are available,
so I'm not gonna talk about who they are
'cause you're gonna listen to them
rather than me talk about them.
And Ekow Yankah and Zachary?
- [Zachary] Lazar.
- Lazar, sorry.
There's a law school
person who has that name.
Anyway, and Tracy Meares.
I was gonna add alter names.
But I wanna start by talking about
the degree to which incarceration
has been very visible,
is very visible and has been
for centuries as a practice,
that it is visible to those
in and outside of prisons
for any of the many public minds or eyes
who want to look or who care to look.
And not only that, but
the fact of incarceration
has been for a long term
advertised as well as debated.
And the practices of incarceration
and the practices of punishment are here.
And I wanna invite, 'cause
it's a wonderful audience,
to think about the range
of text and materials
that are available.
So assuming, there, I'm
in Amsterdam in the 1780s,
the population is declining.
And there is a folio which,
thank you the Beinecke.
And I also need to advertise that
there's an exhibit at the Beinecke,
an exhibit at the law
school on some images
that you can go see
And I have some handouts for that.
So this image is one of
about a hundred in a folio
put together to tell
you "Move to Amsterdam.
It's a great town."
20% of the images are about
how they detain people,
either in orphanages, poor people,
and this is the men's house of correction,
which is the largest of the buildings
of that era being built.
And this is the ad.
This is not anything covert whatsoever.
And when you go inside, and
thank you Bernard Harcour
'cause this one's in color,
the color image is fabulous.
You're watching somebody being flogged.
And this is the ad.
"We keep control, we're
very tidy, we're neat,
we make you do menial work
and we whip you if you don't behave.
Move to Amsterdam."
(audience chuckling)
Now, as of course the invention
of the penitentiary comes,
of course starts to be some concerns.
So not all the visuals look like this.
And if you go to the Yale
Center for British Art,
you'll find this, which is a print after
a painting by Thomas Ryder of the captive.
The Brits are depicting
someone in a French prison,
the Channel fight.
And it's pointing to this kind
of saintly, chained prisoner
to start the call for reform,
and across the continent
and then across the oceans.
And this is Europe and the United States.
Not all the world by any
stretch of the imagination,
although there's a colonial piece.
The efforts at religious
societies to reform,
improve the lot of prisoners,
ramps up with the founding
of social sciences,
of sociology and anthropology
and this thing called criminology.
And the next stop is now a
plaque that was put up in 1970,
but it commemorates in 1870,
the first ever national
Congressional Congress
where the people who were the prison men
met with Rutherford B. Hayes,
welcoming him as the governor,
before he became president,
of Ohio,
to say welcome to these
organizations that are committed to
figuring out how to
run and reform prisons.
And unlike the early part of the 1800s
when we really wanted menial work,
now we're into reformation
and useful work,
some of it of course hugely profit-making
for the people who are doing it.
They talk, they debate.
You can read, I've read hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds
of pages of their materials.
How you punish, which way you punish?
Do you crook, do you da-da-da-da?
And here's an example from
a British prison of 1902
and you're looking at a
disgusting practice called
what they called a tread wheel.
Men being made to go circle seven steps
over and over and over again.
While this is all displayed,
available, seeable
maybe for a deterrent,
Jeremy Bentham wanted you all
to be scared and not do this.
So he wanted the panopticon.
So this is the 1920s.
This is a painting of Marjorie Fry.
Part of it is that in a
world of gender stories,
this gender story needs to
include that there are reformers,
some of whom are women,
some of whom are feminists,
and Fry and her colleagues of
the Howard League in London
are the first speakers I've
found in a variety of documents
that say the words "rights" and "torture."
"Prison is torture and
people deserve rights
and there should be an
international convention."
And the guys who are by then running
the International Penal
Penitentiary Commission
poo-poo the ladies, they
call them "the ladies,"
and say "get rid of them."
But these are incredibly
entrepreneurial smart women
who go to Geneva and lobby
the League of Nations
with these amazing anti-death penalty,
pro "convention for the rights
of prisoners," their words.
And therefore the guys at this
international organization
which is full of
countries that are empires
say "we better draft rules."
And the women convince
the men who draft rules.
And for the first time in 1935,
the League of Nations adopts
the standard minimum rules for
the treatment of prisoners,
which you see are from a
'humanitarian' point of view
and a 'social' point of view.
And what their rules are
just give you heartburn
in terms of how awful prisons are.
So there should be enough food,
i.e. there wasn't enough food.
There should be enough water, et cetera.
Corporal punishment is
generally not acceptable
except in exceptional cases
if a medical person authorizes it.
That is because the Brits love whipping.
It isn't just Amsterdam and
it isn't just elsewhere.
The Brits and the British colonies
have flogging birching and whipping a lot.
And in exceptional cases, a
dark cell, if regulated by law,
i.e. a dungeon is also
permissible as well.
The Caesar rules are disseminated.
This is the frontispiece
from the Home Office
with the Queen's seal,
which tells you that we're
sending them around to everyone.
And then World War II comes.
This international
organization actually meets
in Berlin in the 1930s
because if prisoners have no
rights, because the UN did not,
the League of Nations had
no language of rights,
then fascist, whatever your government is,
we can make things together
to manage the folks we
are keeping in detention,
but when you get to the
United Nations in 1955,
although these are not enforceable,
the new words come in:
"in a world of rights,"
"non-discrimination," and
"the person has a right to
self-determination and liberty."
But then there's the sad caveat:
"unless we need to do something
to control and manage you."
And if you go through
some of their rights,
we are now, "discipline is needed."
We're banning corporal punishment.
There's no longer a dark cell.
But here's what we tolerate.
We tolerate reduced diet as an
euphemism for bread and water
and we tolerate solitary confinement
if it's certified that you can stand it.
Now, of course in the United States
and elsewhere in the world
in terms of colonial imperialism,
of course the centrality
of race in this story.
So there are many pioneers in
the United States in the 1960s
who are individual prisoners
who believe that law will help them.
And they look at the US Constitution
and they say, "law can help me."
And in doing this, this
is Caleb Washington
and the case is called Washington V Lee.
Not George Washington versus Robert E.,
although the people who've
styled the complaint
knew exactly what they were doing.
Alabama had a statute that said
segregation by race meant that
Black and white people
couldn't be chained together
or sleep together in prison.
A lawsuit challenging this in
1966 wins in the lower courts
and in the US Supreme Court they bring
what they call "a statement of questions."
And the question they raise,
this is 1967 in the United States
and these people have the, the
Yiddish word is "chutzpah,"
to say, "Does a prisoner
serving a penitentiary sentence
have a constitutional right
to question the validity of
state statutes requiring
separation by race?"
Which is to tell you
the status of the person
was claimed to be not a person
who had any relationship
to the US Constitution
once it was you were convicted.
And by the way, this is the first term
that Thurgood Marshall is
sitting in the US Supreme Court,
which is the first time
it's not an all white institution itself.
So just to be quickly summarizing,
first of all, it's a
very visible activity.
There are debates about
permissible and impermissible
and the freaks who, the people
who are the serious speakers
of the claim for a
constraint on sovereign power
are the folks who are incarcerated
who say "you can't treat me like this."
And the answer from
justice is, the court says,
"Yes, you can't segregate by race
except, comes a concurrence,
if their racial tensions,
you can take them in account
to maintain security
discipline and good order
in prisons and jails."
That's the mantra.
"Maintain security,
discipline, and good order."
So here come to Arkansas in 1967,
and this is a picture in the newspaper,
thank goodness for newspapers.
And the newspaper says,
"This is the whip."
Arkansas says, "To maintain
good order, we whip prisoners."
And Winston Talley is a guy who says
in this handwritten petition,
"Please people writing,
look at the literature
produced by the people
who are in detention,"
handwriting in a variety of ways
not only to courts,
but to courts included,
"whip, W H I P P, no evidence."
This is a man who's part of,
I've learned some about him,
that he's part of a social movement,
but he understands himself.
He says, "Article eight,
you can't whip me."
And he gets a hearing in federal court.
This is the group of
people who are testifying
as Arkansas has about 60% white prisoners
and is whipping Black and
white people together.
Now of course,
while these people may or
may not be part of movements,
there is of course a huge social movement
of which the Attica
picture is one example.
The Nation of Islam is
organizing in prisons as well.
And there's an effort at what
is profound and serious claims
of the capacity of the
state to require the state
to not punish people in particular ways.
And you get for a little
while federal judges saying,
here's in the fifth Circuit
with Louisiana, Angola,
"We are here, the Constitution's here,
you're in relationship
to the Constitution,
you're us as well."
But as is sadly familiar to many of you,
by the 1980s, we're not here very much.
And the new floor of what is
tolerable constitutionally
is "minimal civilized measure
of life's necessities."
A pathetic floor for this whole thing.
And here, just to bring you
to date in '08 in California,
you have hyper density.
Hyper density, which everybody,
actually the word used
to be called "crowding."
"Overcrowding" is a weird
word that gets added.
But if you go to the 1970s and '80s,
they call it "crowding."
So, overcrowding is here
and anybody who wants
to look at its harms,
the Department of Justice,
this is the document that's out
that is, a trigger warning,
it's horrible to read
about Alabama state prisons.
And of course it's appropriate
to invoke them because
the prisoners have just gone
on strike there in protests.
You can read pages of this.
So, it's not secret, there's
contestation about it,
and the question about what is
permissible in a social order
brings me to the last image,
which is by Faith Ringold,
called "The United States of Attica"
marking the violence that is incomplete.
The last sentence at the
bottom, which is hard to read,
says, "This map of American
violence is incomplete.
Please write in whatever
you find lacking."
Seems to me she is the
words to be the introduction
to the people who are coming to speak.
And I'm incredibly grateful
that they've come and are here
and are gonna talk to us some
about the problems of this,
which they can do either
standing up or sitting
depending on their backs and their spines.
Go for it, Elizabeth, you're next.
Whatever you want.
- I'm gonna sit, I think.
- [Judith] Okay.
- Yes, thank you for that.
And thank you to the
Whitney Humanities Center,
Freedom Reads, the Liman Center,
and of course organizers
Judith Resnik, Dwayne Betts,
Jenny Carroll and Peter Brooks
for inviting me to join this conversation
and all of you for coming.
So, picking up on this slide,
this is actually like the perfect segue.
I wanna think about
the image of the prison
in the public mind in
the era of rebellion,
what could be seen as the opening
act of mass incarceration,
because immediately after
the long hot summers of
the late 1960s and early 1970s,
people of color and Black
people in particular start
getting disproportionately
and systematically locked up
and mass incarceration
as we know it begins.
So what I call the crucible
period of rebellion
lasted from 1964 to 1972,
and every major city burned
during these eight years,
as well as midsize and smaller cities
and rural towns across the United States,
East and West, from the North and South,
the Rust Belt to the Sun Belt,
leading to nearly 3,000 incidents in total
across more than 1,000
segregated communities of color.
Now, nearly all of these
rebellions were sparked
by a police encounter, a
moment of tangibly felt racism,
yet the tens of thousands
of Black and Brown people
who threw rocks and bottles at police,
plundered local stores,
detonated Molotov cocktails
were rebelling not just against
police brutality, right?
They were rebelling
against a broader system
that had entrenched unequal conditions
and anti-Black violence over generations.
So the so-called 'riots'
constituted a set of demands
for jobs, first and foremost,
expand in educational opportunities,
better housing conditions,
and an end to state-sanctioned violence.
These of course were the same demands as
the civil rights movement more broadly,
but policy makers treated the
rebellions as criminal acts,
as crime, not as calls for
full economic and political
inclusion in American society.
So under the banner of the War on Crime,
which President Lyndon Johnson started
in the spring of 1965,
the federal government supported
the expansion of police
and targeted Black, Puerto Rican,
and Mexican-American communities,
accompanied by the militarization
of those police forces
with an arsenal of surplus
weapons and technologies
from Vietnam
and interventions in South
America and the Caribbean.
So the national solution,
the counterinsurgency,
was more police, leading
to more incarceration.
And the effect was to
place low-income families
and their communities under
the omnipresent gaze of police
and to normalize confinement.
Now, we often think of
police brutality as being
the proximate cause of
the collective violence,
as was the response most recently
to the brutal murders of George
Floyd and Breonna Taylor,
which sparked the nonviolent
and violent protests
that we witnessed during
the summer of 2020.
But the rebellions very often began
in response to the
specter of incarceration.
People fought back when police exercised
their most basic legal
authority: making arrests.
According to data calculated by
the political scientist
Christian Davenport
at the University of Michigan's
Radical Information Project,
about 24% of the rebellions
during the crucible period
began in response to an
arrest or an attempted arrest
that was seen in the minds
of participants as arbitrary.
The Watts Rebellion of
1965 and Newark in 1967,
which, along with Detroit of course, are
the 'iconic riots' of the era
in the public imagination,
each began in response to the
arrest of a Black motorist.
People did not want to see
their friends, family, and
fellow community members
handcuffed, detained, captured,
removed from the community,
thrown behind bars, and possibly
sent to far away prison.
In Baltimore, Black residents
challenged officers' arresting
authority with determination,
disrupting arrests on
three separate occasions
in late June 1968, about two months after
the week-long rebellion that followed
the assassination of Martin Luther King.
On June 19th, after an officer
tried to arrest a young man
in the heart of the
Black Upton neighborhood
in front of a growing crowd,
a woman scratched him down his
left arm and took his watch.
The officer sprayed the
woman and others with mace
and the people who
gathered at the scene left.
Less than a week later, a 15-year-old boy
grabbed an officer's arm during
a disorderly conduct arrest,
giving his suspect an opportunity to flee.
The officer hit the boy
and took him into custody.
The next evening, two dozen
teenagers began shouting
at officers Paul
Kirosavich and Norman Stamp
as they attempted to arrest
three people on burglary charges
at around 11:30 in the
Reservoir Hill neighborhood.
A 13-year-old girl jumped on Stamp's back,
forcing him to let go of
two of the of the suspects,
and the men escaped.
So Officer Stamp sees the girl,
who kicked him, clawed him, and bit him.
Eventually, Stamp managed
to put the girl in handcuffs
for resisting arrest,
but suddenly her 14-year-old brother
attacked the officer from behind.
And after a struggle, the
brother was also detained.
Another 14-year-old boy helped free
the third burglary suspect
by assaulting Kirosavich.
The suspects, all three of
them young men, escaped,
and the kids who came to
their defense went to jail.
Viewing the arrests as an injustice
and the potential to be
incarcerated as an injustice,
these young people were willing to
take justice into their own hands
and sacrifice their own
freedom in the process.
Although the informal
arrest prevention campaign
in Baltimore did not directly inspire
a broad rebellion in other cities,
a single arrest could lead to
sustained collective violence
committed by hundreds of people.
For example, in Jersey
City in August 1970,
about 500 Black and Puerto
Rican residents declared
what police called
"open warfare on whites"
in the downtown area
after two patrolmen stopped a vehicle
for a minor traffic violation.
Weeks later in nearby Hoboken,
a six-hour-long drug raid
during which 25 people were arrested,
caused a two-night rebellion.
The prominent 21-year-old
activist Luis Lopez
came to protest the mass arrest
and was subsequently arrested himself for
"interfering with police duties"
and using "obscene language."
By 7:30 PM, 300 to 400
"enraged" Puerto Ricans,
as the Hudson Post
Dispatch described them,
surrounded city hall,
demanding Lopez's release.
About 30 people sat at the intersection
of Washington and 1st to block traffic.
The crowd threw rocks
and bottles at police
and smashed windows in the area.
Lopez continued to protest
the arrest of Puerto Rican
residents in Hoboken,
leading to another rebellion a year later.
It started with an angry confrontation
between Luis and Jamie
Santana, aged 26 and 24,
and a store owner who the brothers claimed
repossessed their television
set under false pretenses.
After the Santana brothers were arrested
for assault with a dangerous weapon,
Lopez led a small group of
activists to police headquarters
to demand the release of the prisoners
and to request a suspension
of the two officers
who allegedly used brutal
force during the arrest.
Soon after Lopez and his group left,
police reportedly received
calls that people were
harassing motorists and passers
by outside of City Hall,
and then when local officers arrived,
a group of about 300 people
began throwing cans,
bottles, and bricks at them,
and the rebellion spread from there.
Seen as an unfair, unjust,
and racist institution,
the siblings in Baltimore,
Luis Lopez and his defenders
and their counterparts in other cities
took the act of policing and
the resulting incarceration
as a form of state violence
that could only be contested
with further violence.
The beginning of mass incarceration
helped bring the crucible
period of rebellion,
the period of frequent
community-based instinctive violence,
to an end.
The systematic imprisonment
of young people of color
that started in this era
effectively removed from cities
a significant portion of the young people
who had committed and sustained
the political violence.
As such, by the mid-1970s,
75% of Black people in American prisons
were under the age of 30.
Although Black Americans have been
disproportionately incarcerated
since the Civil War,
until the 1970s, they amounted to
about a third of the
nation's prison population.
This changed in the mid-1970s,
when Black, Puerto Rican,
and Central and South American groups
began to approach majorities
in state and federal prisons.
The mass incarceration of
Black and Brown Americans
over the past half century
can be partly attributed to
the socioeconomic conditions
that lay at the root of the rebellions.
And that became even worse
as the decade wore on,
with the end of the War on Poverty
and the simultaneous
escalation of the War on Crime.
The fires in Miami in 1980,
in Los Angeles in 1992,
of course nationally televised moments
of mass political violence
that reached a truly unprecedented scale,
are legacies of the
historical trends that began
in the late 1960s and at the
dawn of mass incarceration.
In both cases, people did not erupt
in response to a specific
incident of police brutality,
but instead to groups of police
officers who were acquitted
despite undeniable evidence of abuse.
In the LA case, the
89-second video of officers
striking Rodney King with their
feet and their billy clubs
between 53 and 56 times,
which of course was
the first viral video of police brutality
and the 'proof' of police brutality
in the white public imagination, right?
Did not move the jury in
Simi Valley to convict.
By the time LA exploded,
the prison population had
exploded more than fivefold
from fewer than 200,000 people in 1970
to 1.1 million in 1990.
And it would continue to explode
during the Clinton administration,
with the '94 crime bill
cementing the United States
as the country defined
in part, at least, by mass incarceration.
The violence in Cincinnati
in 2001, Ferguson, Baltimore,
and a handful of other
cities during the Obama years
and in the summer of 2020
occurred in reaction to
exceptional incidents of police
violence or police killings.
There are no longer rebellions
against everyday policing practices,
against arrests and the
specter of incarceration,
a sign that the status
quo has become accepted
in many over-policed and
under-protected communities,
however bitterly.
And in this sense at least,
national and local authorities
won the War on Crime.
And yet, as long as the
criminal legal system
proves time and time again to function as
a means to lock people of
color and poor people away
for long prison terms
and to sanction police violence,
rebellion remains a possibility.
I'll end there. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(Ekow clearing throat)
- Excuse me.
Let me join the course in
thanking the organizers
and our host of this terrific conference.
I was speaking to Peter
yesterday and he said,
"Oh, it's a great group,
this thing will run itself."
And I just pointed out to him that
that's the kind of thing that great hosts,
whether it be dinner parties
or conferences, always say.
They work incredibly
hard behind the scenes
to make things look like
they run themselves,
but they most certainly do not.
And we are grateful for all your work.
Let me also take a moment to
thank you all for being here.
You know, my students have to
sit in rooms and listen to me.
So the the voluntary engagement
is very deeply appreciated.
One of the things that's
great about seeing,
oh, let me turn on my timer.
Forgive me.
As an academic, I really
ought to turn on a timer
lest we be here all day.
One of the great things
about such a group gathering
given the title is the
engagement and belief that
the public imagination matters greatly
when we think and talk
about mass incarceration.
I think that need not be
too long litigated here.
That is to say the public
imagination, and in particular
the public imagination when
it comes to race and crime,
I think is deeply important,
or one might say when
it comes to race at all.
So from Black princes to Black princesses,
whether it be the Black
Panther or "The Little Mermaid"
to secular kings like the Obamas,
it is striking to see how much
images of Blackness in the public media
stir instant passion, anger, and upset.
And I think this is in no
place more powerful than
when it comes to the way in
which race and crime are linked.
So my core idea starts where
many of you have already known
and where many of my
interlocutors on this panel,
in particular to the two people
on our ends, three people,
have engaged with for years,
that is the by now well-known idea that
one of the problems in our
American imagination is
the fusing of criminality and race.
That is in the very idea that
a Black man is presumptively criminal.
That work has been so deeply explored.
I actually don't wanna
litigate it much here.
For those of you who are more interested
or newer to that idea,
I'm happy to recommend
what are now countless really
thoughtful pieces on it.
What I want to instead
speak about is the idea that
how violence is visited on
Black men is in connection to
Black men being presumptively criminal
considered a form of policing.
And that's true,
whether it be by public
or private individuals.
That is to say, the most
provocative way I put it is that
embedded in so much of white history is
a kind of innate view of white privilege
as innate deputizing.
So, this is a set of ideas
that I've been working on for a while.
And indeed, I have to
say, the word "deputizing"
came to me recently at a conference
actually that we were
sharing, and I hoped that it,
indeed, one of the things
I want to test with you
is whether it captures the
idea about which I'm trying,
the idea I'm trying to pin down.
So, what do I mean?
"Deputizing" here is meant to
specify a form of policing,
and that is to say,
deputization highlights
a particular relationship
between policing and violence.
Here, unlike Tracy Meares's work,
which recently has started exploring
the wider use of our term "policing,"
for those of you in the law
schools here or elsewhere,
the term "police power" is
a deep and long historic legal term
with the broadest of uses.
That is to say,
it is as much part of the
police powers of New Haven
that they have zoning laws
as it is that they have
actual police officers.
But it is also true that the
same breath refracts through
our moral and colloquial thinking as well.
So we might talk about policing each other
in the way we behave.
You know, we might say
"I police my children."
It is as far as we know, my main job.
We might say we police
each other's language,
things like that.
And I don't wanna deny
that policing itself,
that is, who is allowed to police who,
instantly invites hierarchy.
So for example, if Tracy
Meares and I are having a fight
over whether or not I should
have cited some scholar, right?
Whenever we're policing academic norms,
it is going to to be
contested whether or not
a student can suddenly pipe up and say,
"Professor Yankah, you
should have" dot dot dot.
One might say, "No, no, no,
Professor Meares and I
are having that debate."
That is to say,
there's hierarchy in
policing that is understood.
But what I wanna do is
focus on policing in a more specific way.
That is to say, policing
is not just about norms,
but in this case I wanna talk
about policing as a form of
justified deployment of norm
guarding and sanctioning.
Fair enough.
But that when I speak about
policing and deputization,
I'm arguing that violence and policing are
in this sense deeply connected, right?
So I'm not just talking
about the way we might
police each other in our
normal everyday behavior.
Deputization is about
the way we police each
other through violence.
And because violence
is especially salient,
deputization, the argument
goes, has its own expression.
So instead, I wanna preserve
the salience of potential violence,
but I also wanna disconnect it from
formally authorized policing by the state.
And that's what I mean by deputization.
So, so far, everybody with me?
All right.
So, deputization in this sense
has existed for a long, long time.
For those of you who
are policing scholars,
actually, better yet, for those of you
who are not policing scholars,
it's always hard for us to remember that
policing is actually
kind of a new phenomenon.
That is, modern policing
is only, I don't know,
160 years or something like this.
- [Panelist] 1867.
- So that's Peel's London, right?
So 18, 140-
- [Panelist] Here.
- Here?
- [Panelist] Yeah, Peel's (indistinct).
- I should do the math.
You get the idea.
One of the reasons I
bring this up actually is
when I teach philosophy 101,
when I rarely get to teach philosophy 101,
one of the interesting things
about philosophy is that
a bunch of things we teach students
are so deeply captured
in our moments, right?
So we say things like
I don't know, let me
give you a silly example.
The sign of a just and
authorized state power is
monopoly over its borders, right?
If you would go back 200 years ago,
that would've been a fanciful idea.
The state just didn't have the power.
I mean, there just weren't the
technologies that we have now
that you could.
So too with policing.
When we talk about the fact that
a justified state has police,
it's actually quite stunning
for us to remember that
police were quite a modern invention.
Why do I say this?
The point is policing,
if you go back only a
century and a half ago,
was often done by what
we call "human cry,"
that is, the justified constable, right?
The police officer would,
the official idea was,
if somebody was a felon,
caught in the act of a felon,
could "raise human cry."
And that would just to be simply to say to
"all law-abiding citizens,
you are now deputies,
come with me and let's
capture this felon," right?
So deputization is a quite powerful way
in which policing has always occurred.
So too, obviously it has
its links in Jim Crow South
where white people could
be deputized at any time
in order to enforce the law
and violence against Negroes,
especially escaped slaves
before the Jim Crow period
and unruly Negroes afterwards, right?
More importantly, I wanna
point out that deputization was
about that feeling continuing
through our history,
the license that white people
had to feel or got to feel
about their ability to enforce violence,
both formal and informal, to
keep Black people in place.
And that's true again and
again, even in less formal ways,
in large swaths of the country.
So I'm thinking, for example,
during natural disasters
and times of threat
when many white communities
simply armed themselves
to police areas with a
firm understanding that
their activities were
not illegal vigilantism,
but something like deputization.
Here then, this of course
was often done with
the tacit approval of
formal police, right?
But here then is why I
want to make the claim that
deputization is important.
This is a difference between
a kind of mindset about deputization
and the kind of mindset
about ordinary violence.
That is to say, deputization
is the idea that
one is not just justified
in using violence,
but that one is authorized.
That is to say, one is, so to speak,
made an arm of the state
when one does this.
So the examples of course
are countless, but think of
George Zimmerman who very
much deputized himself
as a one-man neighborhood watch.
Think of Ahmaud Arbery's
killers, who are complicated
in that they were former police officers,
but when they see a Black man
jogging through the neighborhood,
they simply raise human cry.
They call their friend,
they jump in a truck
and decide they're going
to capture Ahmaud Arbery
and they experience, at
least in their reporting,
his resistance to their asking to stop
as his resistance to their
authorized power, right?
That's a very different kind of thing that
if you and I were engaged in
violence against each other,
to which I'll respond later
to, which I'll return later.
So too Kyle Rittenhouse sees
protestors in Philadelphia
and he goes and gets a long gun
and decides that he's going
to join in his imagination,
not, by the way, entirely unfounded,
numbers of people who are simply going to
impose order on their
community through arms.
and, if less fatally,
Mark and Patricia McClosky
who are famous for having pointed guns at
protestors marching by their home
again, because they felt
they were authorized to.
So what do I wanna say about deputization?
Two points.
One is that, in this sense,
deputization is an innate part
of our white culture, right?
It is the power to think of yourself as
authorized to dispense violence
as against Black people.
Not in a way that does wrong,
but in a way that makes
you an arm of the state.
And I wanna say that this
of course doesn't mean
that violence itself is a new concept.
That would be absurd, right?
But deputization is a powerful concept.
If Zachary and I are engaged
in violence against each other,
we understand ourselves to be engaged in
extra legal behavior and
perhaps even illegal behavior.
Of course, there are communities where
this is more complicated.
I want to make sure that's clear.
There are communities where
the state is sufficiently failing
that people have long
thought of their violence as
authorized by the state.
The mafia would be the most
obvious example, right?
"Cosa nostra" meant "this thing of ours."
"The state was insufficiently protective,
so we will authorize ourselves."
But it is quite something
to think of yourself as
lately empowered to do that
everywhere at any time.
That is to say, rather
than my thinking that
when I hit Zach, I'm doing something wrong
or something to be punished,
or that he and I are just even
dispensing cruelty against each other.
To think that when I hit Zach,
I'm authorized by the state,
that his resistance is resistance to
not my justified power.
It's not self defense, it's policing.
It's authorized policing.
And that my claim is a
powerful kind of thinking
that Black people have not had access to
and that changes white lives,
that changes Black lives.
That that is to say that Black
people live in a world often,
by the way, as an aside, I will say
even as I get passionate about this,
I dislike speaking so broadly.
It is obvious that people
have different experiences,
different places in the
hierarchy of power and wealth.
I don't mean to elide that,
but what is true is that
Black people are aware that
they live in a world where
it's not just that violence
can be visited on them,
that's true of everybody,
but that violence can be visited on them
by people who feel themselves
authorized to do so, right?
I usually actually don't
like to be very personal.
I think there's a kind of
worry that Black scholars are
asked to trade personality
for credibility.
But I will in one moment just point out
when my boys touch other
people's cars, I am frightened.
And my boys are children.
I am frightened because they
will not always be children.
And it is not that people
will respond to them wrongly,
i.e. "don't touch my car, I'm angry."
It's that people will feel authorized
to visit violence on them
because they're presumptively criminal.
That is the power of deputization
that is different than
the power of violence.
That was not in my papers.
Okay.
The question with which
I wanna end is this.
Well, one question which I wanna ask is,
well, okay, one meta
question I want to ask is
does the idea of deputization add anything
to the idea of Black people
as presumptively criminal
and is this simply
racist violence as such?
Or does the idea of
deputization actually change
the way we can think about this?
That's a kind of first order question.
But setting that aside,
the other questions I
oh, my timer didn't beep.
Then I'll really conclude.
Setting that aside, what I wanna say is
I've recently been working on writings
with Keith Humphries at Stanford
on the changing demographics
of mass incarceration.
In particular, as many of you know,
we're in a particular moment of
kind of left-right
convergence on decarceration
and that has meant that the
percentage of Black prisoners
is dropping relative to the
percentage of white prisoners,
indeed dropping faster.
Part of this is kind of feature not bug,
i.e. when you use your criminal law system
to imprison Black people,
if you affect your criminal law system,
you'll free Black people at a faster rate.
What I want to think
about is whether or not
that has an effect of
undermining or destabilizing
the image of Blacks as
presumptively criminal.
And whether that itself has
the ability to undermine
this white innate power of deputization,
the ability of white people
to police Black people through violence.
What I also want to know is can
if this historical image
of the Black criminal
can be combated to drain
the idea of legitimization,
what happens to the idea of deputization?
So for example, there is suggestive work
currently on for felony murder,
which I will not explain,
but the way felony murder turns out
is often used to punish
people disproportionately.
It is often used itself,
not just disproportionately
for their crime,
but it's also often used in
vastly racially
disproportionate ways, right?
So Black people are prosecuted
for felony murder one
in crimes that white people
would not be prosecuted for.
Interesting work has
been recently done where
audit studies have been
done trying to sort out
white names, Black
names, and Hispanic names
to see what potential jurors would do.
And interestingly, while
white jurors were punished
less under felony murder statutes,
Black jurors actually weren't
punished that much more
when jurors were made alert
that these were Black jurors.
That is to say, they may
be guarding themselves
in this new era of thinking
about race and mass incarceration.
But Hispanic jurors were punished
vastly out of disproportion.
So the worry is can we undermine
racial thinking about crime
sufficient to undermine deputization?
Or the worry might be
do we simply push and
hide it into other spaces
where our guards aren't up?
And these are the ideas that
I'm starting to wrest with.
I will stop there.
(audience applauding)
- [Judith] I think we're
standing as you like.
- I'm gonna sit, I think.
I'm gonna see.
- [Panelist] I think it works.
- Does it work?
- [Panelist] It works.
- Now I've got two.
- [Ekow] Take 'em both.
(Ekow chuckling)
(panelists murmuring)
- I'll take Ekow's, I know Ekow's worked.
Let's see here.
And I would like to echo Ekow's thoughts
about thanking everybody and
thanking you for being here.
Can you hear me all right?
- [Judith] A little louder.
- Okay.
I'll try to be a little louder.
I'm very interested in what Ekow just said
about "deputization,"
the word "deputization"
and I think one of the
things you asked is if
feedback was positive or
negative about the word.
And I think it's a very
potent one word way to suggest
a lot of things that
we're talking about today.
And I wanna go from there
to loop back to some of
the things we were talking
about in the first session,
which had to do I think
with the imagination,
the way incarcerated people are imagined
and in particular what
fiction has to say about that.
And if we think about some of
what Ekow just talked about,
I think we're talking about something that
Bernard was talking about
earlier, which is the way that
everything becomes fiction
if you look at it clearly.
The idea of deputizing yourself
and viewing someone else
who is a fellow citizen
as someone who you are in charge of
is an act of imagination.
It's a negative act of imagination,
but it's an act of imagination.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about fiction,
which is what I do, but
I'm gonna start by, well,
I'll just read my presentation
is what I think I'll do.
All right.
My friend, the university
sociologist Marcus Kerr,
recently launched a website
called the Visiting Room.
The Visiting Room compiles
videotaped interviews
he's done over the course of five years
with men serving life at
Angola Prison in Louisiana.
Each of the videos is
vividly unique and intimate.
When I posted the site's
link on my Facebook page,
one of my friends responded.
I just started looking at things,
but anyone who watches would see how
basically normal and human these men are.
And no possibility of parole.
That's insane. That's evil.
It's likely that some of my
other friends who saw my post
had firsthand experience of prison
and so might not be surprised
by the men's stories.
Of course, to understand the
men serving life in prison
are basically normal should
not be surprising anyway.
But for other people,
prison has appeared as an imaginary space,
a kind of blankness covered
over received ideas and images.
I'm (indistinct) as a novelist,
and have been interested for
a long time in the question
"What can fiction possibly do to address
this problem of misrepresention.
We're a long way from "Uncle Tom's Cabin"
or Tugenev's "A Sportsman's Sketches,"
which played important roles in
the movements to abolish
slavery and suffering.
Fiction is no longer in a
position to shift public policy.
Perhaps what it can still do, then,
is at least attempt to
create better images,
in the way of "The Visiting Room."
I'd like to read a passage from my novel
"The Apartment on Calle Uruguay"
and then talk a little bit about it.
(indistinct) Christopher Bell is
going to visit the brother
of his deceased partner
at a prison that is like
Angola in Louisiana.
The brother, Jesse, has a life sentence,
but has received a favorable
parole recommendation
and has a chance of getting
out in a year and a half.
So he's in this sort of a limbo.
Before the visit to the prison,
Christopher Bell was attacked
by one of his neighbors
just as he was planning to leave
the United States for Mexico.
He's a painter.
He gets assaulted by this kid
who happens to slash his eye,
which is an important part of
the body if you're a painter.
All right, I'll just
read a little bit now.
"Jesse sat by himself
at a table by the wall
wearing the jeans and white
t-shirt of a 'convict'
as he always said,
not the street clothes he normally wore.
The moment I saw him,
I wasn't even sure it was him at first.
And when he stood up,
I realized I'd signaled this uncertainty.
He had lost weight,
his hair a little thin on
top, gray strands in it.
But his eyes were so (indistinct)
that he looked younger than before,
younger and also simultaneously as if
even the aging process got distorted
by the climate of where he lived.
He asked how my drive had
been and I told him "fine."
(indistinct) with his
old-fashioned solicitude,
which meant he wasn't just asking.
He'd considered the
risks of the long drive
and was glad I'd made it safely.
I told him I was going meet
Ana in a couple of days
in Texas, a state I'd never seen,
and he told me the state of
Texas always brought to mind
the life he wanted to live
when he got out of here.
A pickup truck, football on TV,
hunting or fishing on the weekend,
a farm maybe, but maybe not.
He pushed his chair closer to mine
and said he wanted to
look in my healed eye.
He been studying an anatomy
since the attack in my living room.
He'd told me this before.
And he put his fingertip on my eyebrow now
and leaned in closer.
"There are six muscles
in the eyelid," he said.
Just in the lid itself, not the eye,
which had its own very
complicated musculature.
When it blinked, the six muscles in eyelid
kicked into action simultaneously.
Flash. 12 reflexes fired.
Muscle tissue, nerve
tissue, microscopic tissue.
"The blade was like a backhoe
coming through all that
delicate tissue," he said.
All the way down to the
level of the synapses.
"It's amazing it healed," I said.
He moved his chair back to the
opposite side of the table.
"So you live in the country now," he said.
"Sold the house, quit the job."
"I should have left a
long time ago," I said.
"It's easy to see it now.
It would've seemed
ridiculous a few years ago."
I went over to the buffet in
the hall to order some food.
Jesse got a double cheeseburger,
a mammoth sandwich that
dripped around his fingers
and was hard to eat.
I had a fish sandwich that was similar.
The taste of the food, the
difficulty of eating it,
the solemnity of where we
were, the fact that I'd paid,
we'd been trying not
think all these thoughts
and both failing,
thinking and eating in
the silos of ourselves.
He was involved with a old
girlfriend from high school
he finally told me.
A woman he hadn't seen or heard from him
in more than 20 years before
she contacted him last fall.
She'd started writing
him letters, then emails,
then talking to him on the
phone and coming for visits.
I knew from conversations
we'd had in the past
that eople actually had
sex in this visiting shed
with its gray linoleum floor
and stifled gray light that
made it feel underwater.
Sometimes they to do it right at the table
with their clothes on,
in front of the guards.
There was a way to push the
video games closer together
to create a space that
was hard to be seen in.
That wasn't the kind of relationship
Jesse described to me now, though.
She was solid, he said.
Down to earth.
She could talk to him about
the most boring things,
the people she worked with,
how none of the stores carried
her kind of cigarettes anymore,
some lipstick she found
that tasted like cake,
and he would listen intently.
When you compared it to
how they fought, he said,
it was like the sweet spot.
Most of his life consisted of
sleep, work call, eating, sleep,
listening to her talk about
some argument with her sister.
Finding a way to take her side
and argue for it sincerely
was like getting high.
She put money on his commissary
and paid for his cell phone.
That was how they talked and texted
and even flirted with each
other in public on Facebook.
He knew that the she was living with
wasn't listening to her.
He said all of that daily life.
If he was honest about it, he admitted
he probably wouldn't listen to it either
if he was the other man.
He knew this, but he
couldn't really believe it
because he was here, not there.
It started to turn into
this whole love in his head,
Jessie and Antonio, like he
could hear the soundtrack.
I worried about the contraband cell phone,
but didn't say anything.
The institution had
special tablet computers
that enabled you to
check your prison email
and download music files,
which cost more than ordinary ones.
And I had bought Jesse
one of these players
and funded it every once in a while,
but now they seem quaint, inadequate.
He was having a love
affair with a real woman
who wanted him to have a
phone and who, Jesse told me,
got angry if he didn't
stay in touch with it.
He said the relationship was
almost as much as about arguing and strife
as it was about happiness.
They were drawn to each
other but always forgot.
They tended to argue and look
for ways to hurt each other.
They must both get off
on it, he said laughing.
He told her she had to
leave the other man.
It was untenable.
He was going to cut it off with her
if she didn't get her own apartment.
But actually, he was just
like that other man, he said.
All threats and no follow-through.
"Masochism," he said shaking his head.
"Is that what this is with me and her?"
"I think it's just
ordinary drama," I said.
I had that kind of feeling
with your sister sometimes,
with Anna.
"Now it's different, I said.
Different movie. He said
different soundtrack.
When I tried to imagine his daily life,
I would see gray, dark
hours or lurid violent ones.
I'm sorry.
When I used to try to
imagine his daily life,
I would see gray, dark
hours or lurid violent ones
instead of the textures and
hues his eyes actually saw,
I still couldn't see what he saw.
I knew that his equanimity
was something I could never fathom.
Okay, I'll leave.
That's it for the fiction
part, I promise you.
Okay, to go back to my
friend's comment on Facebook.
Men serving life in prison are
basically normal and human.
My Facebook friend said
fiction tries to enliven
statements like that through
mundane, trivial details
that can transform abstractions
like "normal" and "human"
into felt realities:
the anatomy of the eye, the
messiness of the cheeseburger,
the contraband cell phone.
Like any art form, fiction
has the potential to
organize the world's
infinite chaos of particles
into a pattern.
Though, because fiction's
medium is language,
it always suggests meaning
or at least the possibility of meaning.
This is what the Jewish
tradition calls "Tikkun Olan,"
or reconfiguring or repairing the world.
My character Jesse contains particles of
people I know or have met,
but he is mostly imaginary,
a figment that I hope is convincing
and not a kind of delivery
vehicle for themes and ideas.
When I heard the topic for this session,
the image of the prison
and the public mind,
my first thought was that
that image is usually distorted or false,
but I was forgetting a part of the public
for whom prison is not an
image, but a firsthand reality.
Perhaps what a novel can do is
at least connect these two
publics in a single story.
I'm gonna try to flesh out
another empty abstraction now,
which is that prison,
that place of violence,
has also been shown to
me to be a sacred space,
like all other spaces.
Little, tiny bit more fiction.
It'll be pain free.
I think this is an email Jesse
writes to Christopher Bell
later in the book.
"I understand why he
would wanna go to Mexico.
He wrote, "It's Trump time."
By the way, this book takes place.
I mean go there to stay.
It got me thinking about
how when I get out of here,
I'll face a totally different world.
When I first came to prison,
there were no cell phones,
no Facebook, barely even any internet.
Guys come out of this place
and can't figure out how to
buy a toothbrush, I'm told.
There's too many choices or
we have to order it online.
A foreign country is
what I'm talking about.
Like you in Mexico,
I'm gonna try to keep one
foot in and one foot out.
You know what I'm saying?
To not forget where I came from.
It's like when I got to the end of
the Book of Exodus in the Bible,
and there's a lot of drama going on.
Moses brings down the 10 Commandments.
They're about to cross over
into the promised land,
enemy territory.
It's where a war is about to set off,
and then they stop everything right there.
And there's maybe five
chapters just telling you
how they built the tabernacle,
this movable temple
with the Ark inside it.
What kind of architecture there was,
what kind of columns they used,
the different stones
and the types of wood,
the ornamentation.
They tell you exactly how much
gold and silver and
bronze they used to build
the gates and the doors and
the hinges and the altar.
Part of the ornamentation was
badger skins and ram skins they dyed red.
I remembered all this because
I could really see it.
They're trying to paint a picture,
make you sit with it for a long time
before the story moves
forward, take it in.
The temple is movable.
They're going to take it with
them to the promised land.
But what they don't realize is that
they're already in the promised land.
The actual arrival is
just a matter of time.
The whole Book of Exodus just ends
with this long description of the temple.
This was how it looked, the end.
And I was like, "What the?"
And then I realized why
they did it that way.
It's because it's not about
some specific piece of land.
It's about this other
space that is everywhere.
And I'm gonna leave it there.
I wanna just say one thing now.
I have a friend who published a book
about a year and a half ago now.
His name is Quntos.
Quntos KunQuest, whose
novel is called "This Life."
Quntos has a life sentence
in Angola, is still in there.
And any of you who are
interested in hearing
what fiction sounds like
written from the pen of
someone who is in prison, I
really recommend that book.
It's kind of a masterpiece.
I really admire it.
It's called "This Life"
by Quntos KunQuest.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- [Judith] Commenting, Tracey.
- All right.
Is this working?
Yeah, so since everyone else has
already thanked the organizers,
and those of you for being here,
I'm going to take the first opportunity
to thank the speakers,
so thank you very much.
You might think that I might
be dreading a little bit
what I'm about to do
since I have just heard all
of these for the first time
and I now have to say something
hopefully interesting,
maybe profound and helpful
to those of you sitting in
the audience to think about.
But I'm actually quite joyful
about this task because
it was an incredible experience
to hear all of you speak.
And actually, having been
here for the first session,
I'm also gonna attempt
to draw some connections
between the first panel and this one.
So here it goes.
So Judith starts out by talking about
incarceration and visibility.
And I think using the term
visibility is an interesting one
in the context of the
subject of the conference,
you know, incarceration and imagination.
What role does visibility play
when we are engaged in the
project of imagination?
And so I wanna use that
frame, the idea of visibility,
contrast it with the concept
of what's not secret,
which is also something that Judith said,
and just sort of trouble the idea that
visibility and not secret are equivalent,
which I think Judith sort of suggested.
I'm not saying that that's what you meant,
that's just literally what
you said, I wrote it down.
And how the juxtaposition of those terms
helps us to think about
the project of imagination.
So that's one frame.
The second frame is something
that Zachary offered.
He asked the question
"What can fiction do to
address misrepresentation?"
And that made me think about
the interaction between
representation on the one hand
and misrepresentation on the other
in the context of visibility, right?
I think there, what Bernard
said in the last session,
his offering, or maybe
we'll call it a provocation,
that we're all engaged in fiction.
What does that have to do with
visibility on the one hand,
representation, misrepresentation,
and then this project of imagination.
So that's the overall frame,
and I'm gonna take each
presentation in turn,
hopefully still being under time.
So, Elizabeth starts out
with this idea of, you know,
she talks about the image of
the prison in the public mind
in the context of rebellion.
And then the process of
rebellions that she describes,
I think would immediately
cause us to think about
what are we talking
about when we say public?
Obviously there are lots of publics.
I mean, for Elizabeth's subjects,
she's, I think, talking
about the parts of the public
involved in rebellion
itself, and these kids.
And one of the things that
immediately came to mind
and listening to the details
that Elizabeth was offering
was a connection between the first session
and in particular, Joy's
comments about fugitivity
(indistinct)
where, you know, Elizabeth gives us
this incredibly vivid
picture of teenagers,
I don't even wanna call them teenagers.
I mean, is a 13-year-old a teenager?
Like, that's a child, right?
They're babies who are, in her terms,
sacrificing their own freedom
against the specter, for them, of imprison
so that they have an
imaginary of what this is.
You know, is it visible to them?
What is it that they see?
To borrow another phrase
that Zachary offered,
Is this a movie in their head?
Is something else happening?
But anyway,
their actual action of
sacrificing their freedom.
And I'm thinking about that
next to the prison narratives
that Joy was talking about
that are excluded, these
narratives of fugitivity.
So one question for you is just
how do we think about these
kids engaged in that act
in a context where
in incarceration people
are doing, is it opposite?
I don't even know how to
think about fugitivity
next to what they are doing,
but I would like invite
you to think about that
and talk about that.
The next thing that Elizabeth
talks about in her comment,
she's talking about
maybe their imagination is
about mass incarceration.
And then you tell a story about
removal of many young people
from neighborhoods and places where,
and I'm again quoting you,
it's, well, maybe this is
my interpretation of it,
removing and quelling activism, right?
This activism, these
rebellions are quite visible,
I mean visible in the
regular, normal, everyday way
we think of visibility.
It's not an imagination, right?
We see it.
And if this quelling is removing people
and putting them in prison,
prison that Judith tells us is not secret,
but it's also not visible,
certainly not in the same
way that rebellions are,
I think there's a way in
which the incarceration,
even if people are still
engaged in activism,
it's obscuring the nature of the activism.
I wonder if that's the link to fugitivity.
I don't know, but maybe
that's a jumping-off place.
And then the final
thing that's I wanna say
in connection with the first panel
is that there's a way in
which the mass aggregates,
they are not secret, not visible,
but to make visible and
legible that kind of activity
might require some kind of individuation.
Which, you know, those of us on this panel
were invited by Zachary to go to
the website that he spoke about,
which was incredibly compelling
for me to read these,
listen to these individual stories.
And then I sat through the
first panel and then I thought,
"Huh, am I supposed to think
about these individual stories
in the same way, as
compelling in the same way
given, you know, the
comments that Caleb offered."
I'm just not sure.
So, you know, question in there somewhere.
Okay, for Ekow, he is giving us
this incredibly evocative
concept of deputization.
And I wish I could remember
the name of the philosophy
student at offer at Harvard
who actually brought this up
at this conference that
Ekow and I were at.
It was really jarring and also generative.
I think it's a really helpful concept,
but here's a thing to think about, right?
You note the human cry,
which creates a concept of deputization,
which is in a sense
pre-state or pre-modern state
as we understand it, right?
It's not regulatory.
And here I'm connecting with
the talk that I just gave
and it's certainly pre-regulated
police power in the US
as we think about it.
Maybe not the continental version.
So we go from deputization to, you know,
here's a timeline, state creation,
if we're gonna call the
beginning of the modern state
to use Bill Novak's formulation sort of.
The New Deal, so now we're
in like the 1930s, 1940s.
You say, "well of course
it's not that deputization
goes away, it just becomes less visible."
So there's that frame again, right?
It's that it's not secret or is it secret?
How do we think about its visibility?
And to the extent that
it is visible today,
of course it's not the
human cry so much as it's,
do I wanna call it an
implicit deputization?
So, you know, 'Permit Patty'
by calling on the police
to police activity of folks,
you know, the Black
minister who is very kindly
watering his neighbor's garden
when the neighbor is on vacation,
and when police are called, in that case,
the person calling the police,
is that an implicit deputation
that fits in with your model?
Or is that pushing your concept too far?
Because I think one
answer you might have is,
"well, I'm actually talking
about their own use of violence
and not calling upon the state."
But then how do we think about that line?
Again, I think the ways in
which we think about line
depends on ideas of visibility
and how we think about
what visibility means.
Is it just something that we know
or is it something that we need to see?
Is it the movie in our mind, right?
And then for you, Zachary,
what I thought was fascinating
about the fiction you shared
was how vivid the quotidian was.
So, right, you know,
I just became a
pescatarian and I'm hungry,
So when you started talking
about the fish sandwich,
I was like, you know, "Where
is that fish sandwich?"
I could kind of smell it actually.
And so that starts to
bring in other senses.
So when we're talking about visibility,
are we talking about
something that we see?
Are we talking about other senses?
Which brought to mind for me
this book I just just picked
up, I haven't read it yet,
but it's by a journalist
whose name is Ed Yong
and it's something like
"The Immense World of Animal Senses."
And so he talks about all of
the things that humans miss
because we can't see
UV light and you know,
our hearing is not as keen as my puppies.
And he talks about
these insects and plants
that vibrate on plant leaves,
and if you could actually
translate it into sound,
you could actually hear a symphony.
But you know, all the little bugs I guess
are feeling in their feet
or something, I don't know.
I don't know exactly how it works.
Like I said, haven't
finished the book yet.
But you know, the question is
when we're trying to
come to conclusions about
the role of visibility in imagination,
would you maybe make an argument that
what fiction does in the vivid quotidian
is to allow us to push the
boundaries of our senses
and then that's what's really
required for imagination?
And if so, then visibility,
just to start to come
back to where I began,
might not be the word we want to use.
That's it. Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- [Judith] We have
exchanges among ourselves,
but we want to start by inviting
any comments or questions.
Caleb, we'll start with you.
And please introduce yourself,
and I think you need
to scream a little bit.
Oh, microphones are coming to you.
So just reintroduce yourself as well.
- Hi, Caleb Smith.
Thanks for this really illuminating panel.
I really appreciate it.
I wanted to pick up, Tracey,
on something you said about,
you and I can pick up
the individuation thing,
but really about Ekow's paper
and the concept of deputization,
which I found really valuable
and I do think this is
one of the places where
intellectual work can have
some leverage actually,
is by introducing concepts
that then just get picked up
and they condense a lot of thinking
and they have a life in the culture
and they allow people to name phenomena.
But like Tracey, my
specific question was about
whether the state is the
authorizer of deputization.
If I think about January 6th,
I think about the state as a threat to
the felt deputization of the people there.
If I think about
what people think Second
Amendment is protecting them from,
it's from state encroachment
on their deputized power
to do the kinds of things
that you're describing.
So I wondered if, and I do think
there are moments of quite
clear state authorization.
"If you see something, say
something" is an example.
But I wonder if something
like, to me it seems,
like in some of the cases
you're talking about,
it's something like 'the nation'
and a kind of white nationalism
that's authorizing the deputization,
which can actually then be
turned against the state
as being secular, multicultural,
limiting on this kind of power.
So, I also do think there's a kind of
expectation of exoneration
that's built into it, so fair.
But I'm asking, I just
wanted to think about
whether there's even a
certain kind of more mystical
or fascistic deputizing power
at work here than the state
as that is because there's
obviously a lot of, you know,
white nationalist anti-state
sentiment of its own type.
- So, thank you for the question, Caleb.
Thank you for the question.
So this is, I mean, as many
of you know, this is actually
the really great moment
when you have an idea,
you think it has real shape,
but you don't quite know it yet.
Because after this,
after a year or so of defending an idea,
you're just sort of like
trying to survive, right?
So this is fun because
I really don't know the
answer to your questions.
I'm, you know,
in a way that perhaps is
insufficiently protective,
just thinking with you all.
But here are a couple thoughts I do have.
So I take your question as
of a piece with Tracey's
When does the ability to cast your hand,
wave power at people become deputization,
when, after all, it can
be calling the police
to do something that the police, you know,
to enforce essentially your social norms.
"I don't want this person barbecuing."
Or is it, as I was trying
to, I think, encircle,
when you feel authorized
to use force yourself?
So I'm gonna just, so
that I don't go on and on,
I'm gonna use three examples,
say they're on a spectrum,
but say I want deputization to pick out
a particular end of the spectrum.
So one example is self-defense, right?
People feel authorized to use self-defense
and use violence in self-defense.
And it's a powerful authorization.
Indeed, when you teach
self-defense and criminal law,
one of the really interesting things is
it's hard to give a
particular justification
of self-defense, but nobody's
willing to give it up.
It's one of the most
deeply felt moral claims
that I can use violence to
protect myself as against you.
But I don't think that's deputization.
People feel that as a
kind of natural rights.
And that's interesting to me.
I said three examples,
I'm gonna use four cause you gave me one.
The Second Amendment I think
is something like that.
It is a felt kind of natural right.
That some people, at least
in the American psyche
and very few other places,
and I don't, I think you're
right, it is not, you know,
if you were to tell most people
that self-defense is a state
granted right, they'd say no.
To the extent they think
about it, they'd say no,
it's a state granted recognition of
some deeper natural right.
And I think that people who
either deeply are committed to
or fetishize the Second Amendment,
think of it as something like that.
January 6th is an
interesting counterexample
'cause I actually do think it's
an example of deputization.
One of the interesting things
about the January 6th rioters
is that they resist the phrase
"January 6th rioters," right?
Indeed, the late breaking news of
the subpoena of the former president
is precisely because, the claim
is, he misled these people
into thinking they were deputized.
These were not people who said
"something's gone wrong with the state,
thus I'm overthrowing it."
These were people who
it is deeply important to them
that they hold onto the claim
that they're patriots
because they were deputized.
And my point is that there's
something important about that.
They wouldn't hold onto it so dearly
if it weren't important.
And then lastly, I wanna say
I think that's the end of
the spectrum I wanna get to,
when people feel authorized themselves
to use their violence.
And I wanna say it's even
different than self-defense.
Again, it's a spectrum.
One of the things that's difficult about
many instances of violence on Black people
is that it's described as self-defense.
And we know that the self-defense
is deeply racially refracted, right?
That the Black man sneezed
and thus self-defense.
But what I wanna say is
that's what frightens people
when it comes to racial violence.
It's not just that you
might be violent towards me
or you might want my wallet.
That happens in the world.
It's that you feel authorized to do so.
And that's what I wanna pick out
that I think is on the
further end of the spectrum.
- Question in terms of
language is about the word,
first of all entitlement.
But also I keep thinking gender
and violence against women
and the gender of the interaction
as needing to be engaged as the authority
to be violent against a
person in your household.
- Yeah.
- And how that form of entitlement plays
and whether you wanna,
deputizing maybe a subset of
an entitlement to engage,
some of which could come from,
so there's obviously more we
want to probe in trying to
understand the parameters
of the imagery and claim.
- That's really helpful.
I don't wanna dominate this,
but I would say that's
really helpful because
I think you might think, for
example, that violent men
dispensing violence
against women 200 years ago
was seen as both entitled and deputized.
And now some men still
think it's entitled,
but I think very few men
think it's deputized.
Very few men would say
"actually the state would
authorize this" any longer.
- [Judith] Unless we think
of abortion, but let's go-
- Yeah.
(audience awwing)
- [Audience Member #1] And very quickly,
listening to Ekow talk
and then Caleb's response,
I just couldn't help but contribute
something minor thinking
about deputization.
I realized that
reading "Racecraft" by
Barbara and Karen Fields
was the first time in my life
when somebody explained to me
so clearly what ideology is,
and if I have their definition correct,
ideology is not something that
you memorize and then repeat.
It has to be enacted over
and over and over again
to do its real work.
So I was thinking deputization is
the enactment of ideology
over and over again
regardless of the four
types you just cited,
what it's doing is spreading
and reproducing itself.
And like I was, I'm sorry,
I'm live in Los Angeles,
but the president of our
city council Neri Martinez
said on tape, which was
reproduced on Reddit,
that her fellow councilman Mike Bonin,
I'm sorry, it's very disturbing,
his adopted Black son, she
said she needed to be able to
take him around the
corner and beat his ass.
This is, we're talking
about a two-year-old child.
This, I'm sorry, this is very,
very disturbing, but it is,
I think the reproduction of ideology
in her self-deputization
casually in that moment.
And so she's even calling
upon an imaginary space
where people are continuing
to do this kind of work.
I think maybe in a way,
does it relate to Elizabeth
Hinton's wonderful piece
about the protest movement?
Are we also, like, why do we
have to go out in the streets
over and over and over again
every time we witness
state-sanction violence?
Is it also our work to
reproduce a counter-ideology?
- Obviously I wanna let
Elizabeth (indistinct),
but I just want, first of
all, thank you for that.
I just wanna add one last
smallest of corrections
is that Jacob, his son,
is actually eight now.
And I know this 'cause Mike and Sean
are actually friends of mine.
- [Audience Member #1]
Oh, they keep saying that
he was two or three years
old and this was a year ago.
- So, they're friends of mine actually.
And so I've had to live, I
mean, I don't pretend it's,
but you know, it's been painful
to be in touch with them.
I remember when they adopted Jacob
and I played with Jacob in their backyard
and that kid is loved.
Sorry.
- Thank you for the question,
and I think in some ways
it relates to the points
that Tracey was making about fugitivity.
Unfortunately I was unable to hear
Professor James's remarks,
I couldn't make it to the morning panel.
But I think, you know, the
example of the kids is this,
they literally allowed
the kids in Baltimore,
allowed the suspects
who were being arrested
to become fugitives, right?
I mean, I think, you know,
and that's in some ways
the point that I ended on.
As long as we have violence
sanctioned by the state,
the state has a monopoly on violence,
and with that, the people,
white people in particular,
are deputized to enact violence.
And I think, you know, in
response to Caleb's point
and also thinking about
deputization and January 6th,
you know, it's about white supremacy,
white supremacist ideology
that is slippery in terms
of its ties to the state.
So, you know, when
Donald Trump tells people
"Come to the Capitol, it's gonna be wild,"
storm the capital,
that's that state-sanctioned
white supremacist violence,
which has always been part
of the American state.
But as long as we're
continuing to live in this
where some groups of people are fugitives,
some groups of people are captive,
then it is, you know, the responsibility
and a natural response of those
conditions to contest them.
I mean, one of the big things
I didn't get into it in this talk,
but the book "America on Fire"
from which I draw in this work
is that violence precipitates violence,
it's a cycle of violence,
of state-sanctioned violence
and then community violence,
insurgency and counter-insurgency
that we've been stuck in
because of our economic systems,
our ideologies, et cetera.
- [Judith] We started
a couple minutes late,
so I'm gonna invade lunch
a teeny bit and invite,
and I think the way to do it
is there are a few hands up.
So we're gonna take the hands
that are up and listen to you
and then everybody will
get their closing comments
in relationship to you and otherwise.
And the people with microphones
are better than me at running around.
Please introduce yourselves,
but please put your hand up high
and so we can grab all your comments
and then have a response.
Go ahead, start.
- [Rich] Hi, my name is Rich Viada,
I'm with the Prison
Education Program at NYU
and I wanna say thank you
for this entire day, really.
I am one of the coordinators there.
I do reentry work and I'm also a poet,
and indeed I'm a poet that is
steeped in a lot of those traditions
that came out of those rebellions,
that were spoken of so eloquently,
during the sixties and seventies.
And as such, our literature,
Nuyorican literature,
Black arts movement, Black nationalism,
a lot of that stuff is informed by
writers who were formerly incarcerated.
And one thing I haven't heard
yet, unless I missed it,
is the literary imagination
from that liminal space, right?
From the space that is not incarcerated,
but who is bringing the
experience of trauma,
and I do social work, right?
So trauma's always part of that.
The experience of trauma and the time lost
into a world that has
in large part moved on
or moved away or moved
in different directions.
So I'm curious, in any of your readings,
if you've come across,
and we're gonna hear from
formerly-incarcerated writers
later, which is awesome,
but my question to you is
about the theory behind it
and some of the thinking that
maybe some folks have put on paper
around writing from that space.
And I'm curious if any of your readings
you've come across, and this
could mean centuries ago.
I don't know of writers who
are talking about that process
and I wonder if there might be
a recommendation for a reading or two
for someone who has students
who are writing from there.
(panelists speaking faintly)
- [Sonali] Hi, my name
is Sonali Chakravarti,
I'm from Wesleyan University,
and my research is about juries,
which are a very specific type of public
whose imagination of
prisons and of defendants
carries a lot of weight.
And I'm curious if the panelists feel that
there might be any movement in
the way jurors in this country understand
the different aspects of this story.
And in addition to that,
there's a huge need to have
more racially-diverse juries certainly,
but I'm just also curious if you see
the possibilities of change
in the imagination of jurors.
- I think there were a
couple other hands over here.
(indistinct)
(panelists speaking indistinctly)
- So mine was kind of related to,
and thank you Professor Hinton.
(Nasser chuckling)
But I'm Nasser, Yale undergrad.
So I guess my question, it
was kind of thinking with
the January 6th riots.
So I remember, I was
actually my APUSH class
and we were like watching it live
and we saw the gallows for Mike Pence.
And I was thinking too,
the same people who
were motivated that day
had the gallows for Obama
and actually putting like
dolls of him being hung.
And I guess you refer to
him as a secular king.
I thought that was interesting.
And I guess, I'm just trying
to think out loud here.
So it was Obama, he was like in Indonesia,
he was even going to, the
mother says, Islamic schools,
he's Kenyan, he has a Muslim middle name,
and he's the head of a white government.
And that must have caused
confusion for people who were,
you know, as you were saying,
being sanctified to use this violence.
And I guess maybe they
felt betrayed by Mike Pence
(Nasser chuckling lightly)
and that he deserved,
that Mike Pence deserved
the same punishment as
someone who was Black.
But Obama might not be,
like, African-American.
He's like a, he's like an
Eastern Black, you know?
And I want to see how
that confusion led to
the same resulting anger and punishment
through such a very American
violent way of punishment,
which is the lynching.
So that was what I was wondering.
- Thank you.
There are hands from the
back, at least two or one.
(panelists speaking faintly)
- [Audience Member #2] So,
thank you for everything.
- Scream a little bit,
it's a little (indistinct).
- [Audience Member #2]
Okay, you can hear me now?
So thanks to the panel.
- The room doesn't have perfect acoustics.
- [Audience Member #2] Okay.
So I was wondering if
you could say more about
the distinction between
self-defense and violence.
I know seminarians who created
nonprofits in New York City
around domestic violence,
intimate violence.
And the statement, along
with some Buddhists, is
you can use force against violence,
but force is not a synonym for violence.
So then self-defense
has a distinct category.
- That's interesting.
- I think there's one more
hand there. Yes, please.
- [Andrew] Hi, Andrew Clark from Yukon.
I'm interested in the
concept of punishment,
and Judith, in your initial slides
when you talked about prison,
there's a lot of
punishment that's in there.
And then the idea, Elizabeth,
that you talked about,
the crucible period and
the hyper-incarceration
which infused punishment even
more into the carceral space.
And then the idea of deputizing
and who gets deputized
to punish within prison.
And then going to the fiction narrative of
how can we change this?
And when we're looking at other countries
that don't view prison
as a punishment scheme,
but see as the taking away
of liberty as punishment
and the role of a prison
guard or correction system
is actually rehabilitation,
is there a way to change that narrative
from someone that's been
deputized to punish,
to be deputized to actually help?
- Well, Tracey, do you wanna go?
Let's be geographic and go back,
everybody who has any comments
whether intersecting with these questions
or the exchange among the
panels, if we go back this way.
- I don't have any answers
to those questions.
- You can respond to any of the comments.
(panelists chattering)
- I don't know, I have
to think about it more.
- Okay.
(panelists chuckling)
- So Zachary?
I know there's a lot out there, so.
- There's a lot out there.
- So you get to select something.
(indistinct)
- (indistinct)
I think we've been talking a
lot about language actually.
I think we've been talking about, oh,
I can't remember what
Joey's point was just now
about distinguishing violence and force,
using the word deputization
to pinpoint a number of
things with one word.
And I think what I'd like
to say about that is just,
is pretty simple,
that I think that we live
in a culture in which
we're bombarded with
images, images, images.
And I think language is
one way to resist that
and to get past that.
And I think you said something interesting
about senses in general,
and I was just reading this
book about Jewish mysticism
and it's talking about how
there's a difference between
wisdom and understanding.
And that wisdom is a flash of knowledge.
It's God is sending some
sort of energy that gives you
this flash of knowledge,
which is sort of I guess like intuition,
and then past that is understanding,
which is when you take that flash
and you analyze it and particularize it.
And that's considered a next phase,
that's a higher phase than
wisdom, actually understanding.
And I think that's what
language is helping us to do.
And I think that that's
what this symposium
and things like it are
are useful in doing.
- I've been given a lot of time,
so I won't take too much more.
On your, first of all, thank
you for your wonderful work.
I don't know a lot about
people who've written inside,
but Dr. James has a set of anthologies
which I just became aware of.
So you might wanna speak to her
or just Google her and buy
everything she's written.
(panelists chuckling)
Also an idea, I'm planning on doing so.
I should say Professor and Doctor James.
But there's been so much
offered, I just wanna say
Elizabeth, I love this question of
the kids fighting in Baltimore,
allowing others to become fugitive.
Sonali, you know how much I
appreciate your work on juries.
I really want to think about that.
I actually think that's
a really important one,
and the way in which, so
when I teach criminal law,
there are just a lot of stories about
the disconnect between jurors
in particular when the juries
are not racially diverse.
And now you're starting
to see that change.
You pointed out,
something odd about the Rodney King video,
the analogy I always make is
if you finally believed your wife
after she complained
for years about her boss
because you saw the video,
your relationship would've both taken
a step forward and a step back, right?
'Cause it's sort of like,
"Well, I complained to
you since time immemorial,
but you had to see the video."
So I think it's complicated.
On the Obama point, I
think it's a great point,
thank you for that.
What I wanna say is something like
I think you can be patriotic
without thinking you're authorized.
So you can be a patriot of
a lost state, for example.
There are people who thought
they were fighting for
the state that was taken away from them.
And there are people who
think they're authorized
by the current state, and
I wanna disentangle that.
And likewise, I wanna disentangle
self-defense versus violence
along the same lines.
I think self-defense comes
closer to the idea of force,
the idea that it's an
innate authorization,
whereas violence is more
what I'm pointing at
in deputization.
I'll stop there.
Thank you all for your comments,
they've been tremendous.
- Yeah, yeah.
I just, this has been a
really enriching conversation.
So I wanna thank my fellow
panelists once again
and all of you for your really
thought-provoking questions.
I guess just picking up on the last one
in terms of trying to end
maybe on a hopeful note,
thinking about what help might look like,
how we can reframe some of these things,
it picks up on my last comment
in the sense, you know, we
know what the solutions are.
I mean that's, you know,
the people who felt like
they had no other recourse
but to enact various forms
of violence against the state
knew that the solution was
resources into under-resourced communities
and jobs and better
schools and redistribution.
the Kerner Commission in
'68 says all of this, right?
And so, I mean, I think that's
why the questions of this
conference are so interesting
because in order to actually bring about
the kind of form of governance
that would be necessary
to do that, which is, you know,
what I think Defund is really all about,
calling for a different
approach to governance
given that these punitive strategies
have failed to actually
keep communities safe.
How are we going to then
move the public imagination
to be able to not 'other' people,
to de-link people of color, Black people
from ideas about criminality
and to make more visible perhaps
in order to raise that awareness,
these underlying problems
and the failed policies.
So, you know, in a lot of ways
that's the task before us.
But the imagination is so key within that.
- So, you raised, I mean,
I think this worlds of
language in act, and thinking
what these meanings and
sensory experiences are.
And there's this idea of the sovereign,
whether the deputy is the quasi-sovereign
or the self-understood
sovereign in the household
and the non-sovereign.
And the underlying question is
what can we do to each other
in what level of authority?
And there are some things
that have been debated
like whipping or starving
that for some social orders
we take off the table.
It isn't that it isn't happening.
It's that we don't say it's authorized,
when we disavow that authority.
And the current struggle
is what do we disavow
and what do we refund as
well as what do we defund?
And it's been incredibly moving
participating in a
conversation with you all
around these incredibly
weighty topics in a scary time.
I think I'm supposed to
announce, or actually better yet,
well, we wanna first of all thank Diane.
And also I wanna thank,
you've been incredibly
logistically engaged
and in terms of when you were
saying things just happen,
things don't just happen.
They happen because people work
hard at making them happen.
So I think we all need
to pause to thank you.
(audience applauding)
(panelists applauding)
(gentle ambient music)